>>Joe Gregorio: Hi, I am Joe Gregorio and
I work for Google in developer relations.
As part of our on going series on Atom Publishing
Protocol, today we are going to be covering
some of the advanced features, if you haven't
had a chance yet please go to back and watch
the introduction to the atom publishing protocol
which will cover all the basics. So let's
begin, in this presentation we goanna be covering
four advanced features that we had not previously
covered; Paging, Drafts, Category Documents
and the Slug header. Paging: Paging is for
what happens when you have too many entries
for a single feed document. Previously we
talked about you would go and do a get on
a collection, and you would retrieve the feed
document and within that feed document there
would be entries and each entry would correspond
to a web Blog entry. If there are a lot of
entries putting them all into a single feed
would actually be a bad idea there could be
tens, hundreds or thousands of entries. The
paging that is built in the atom publishing
protocol allows you to control how many of
those entries you are actually going to receive.
The server decides how many entries go into
a feed and you retrieve that feed and you
would like more entries you would follow the
next link seen here. So it's a link element
with the relationship of next and you retrieve
with a get element and when you arrive, when
you do that get feed you will receive yet
another feed and or retrieve the next batch
of entries. Similarly that feed may contain
another link element with the next batch of
entries within it and you can continue to
follow it in a chain until you get all the
entries that you want. Drafts: Here we are
talking about editing an entry without making
it public; if I post an entry to a collection
I can add the App control element and inside
there add the draft element with the value
of yes .That tells the publishing system to
keep it as a draft and not to make it public.
It will still show up at the collection feed
and I can still edit it, add gets and puts
within it, I can delete it and remove it from
the collection, but it will remain as part
of and will not update the actual web Blog
itself and it will stay out of the public
feed. When I change this value from yes to
no or remove the draft element completely
it will no longer be a draft and when I update
that entry it will be made publicly available.
Category documents: You can add category elements
to your entries and this is part of the atoms
indication formula. What we need to know thou
in the publishing scenario is what categories
are available to the client to use when he
creates an entry, those are actually listed
in the service document and in here we can
see that there are two category elements that
are possible to use that is Joke and Serious
in the skin which are defined by a Uri :http//example.org/extras-cats.
Categories are listed in the collection element
in the workspace that you are working with
in the service document. Now there could be
a lot of categories elements that are possible
to use and another situation you could run
into is were you have categories that you
have to reuse them among different collections.
So an alternative way of listing this information
is to actually create a stand alone category
document and just reference the URI For that
.So here we have a categories element and
just as an HREF and if I do a get on that
URI I would actually retrieve a category document
as you can see here and this is the exact
information that we got in the service document
but I can now reuse it in multiple collection
by just referencing that URI .An optimization
that you see here is that the skin has actually
been lifted up and is in the App categories
element and so it does not appear in each
of the atom categories elements below this
is just an optimization so that you don't
have to keep repeating the same information
and it still means the same thing. The Slug
header suggests to the server what should
the URI of the entry be. This is just a suggestion
to the server and the server can ignore this
and it is optional to implement this, and
that is actually done by including a slug
header when you post to create a new entry.
And that's it those are the four advanced
features of the atom publishing protocol that
were not previously covered in the atom publishing
protocol presentation and that's it. Thanks
very much and have fun.